(Music)
[music by Moby]
[Grand Canyon]
Narrator: Many of the tests are conducted
while Yves is strapped onto the wing,
because Yves' body
is an integral part of the aircraft.
[Wind tunnel tests]
Narrator: The wing has no steering
controls, no flaps, no rudder.
Yves uses his body to steer the wing.
Stefan Von Bergen: Well, he turns
by just putting his head
on one or the other side.
And sometimes he assists that
with his hands,
sometimes even with the leg.
He's acting as a human
fuselage, so to say.
And that's quite unique.
Narrator: When he arches his back,
he gains altitude.
When he pushes his shoulders forward,
he goes into a dive.
[Swiss Alps]
[Strait of Gibraltar crossing]
[English Channel crossing]
Commentator One: There he goes.
There is Yves Rossy.
And I think the wing is open.
So our first critical moment, it's open.
He is down. Is he flying?
Commentator Two:
It looks like he's stabilized.
He's starting to make his climb.
Commentator One:
There's that 90 degree turn.
He's out over the channel.
There is Yves Rossy.
There is no turning back now.
He is over the English Channel
and under way.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a historic flight has begun.
[Images: National Geographic]
Commentator Two:
And as he approaches the ground,
he's going to pull down
on those toggles to flare,
slow himself down just a little bit,
and then come in for a nice landing.
Commentator One: There he is.
Yves Rossy has landed in England.
Bruno Giussani: And now
he's in Edinburgh. Yves Rossy!
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
And his equipment as well.
Yves, welcome. It is quite amazing.
Those sequences were shot
over the last three years
in various moments of your activities.
And there were many, many others.
So it's possible to fly
almost like a bird.
What is it like to be up there?
Yves Rossy: It's fun. It's fun.
(Laughter)
I don't have feathers.
But I feel like a bird sometimes.
It's really an unreal feeling,
because normally you have a big thing,
a plane, around you.
And when I strap just this little harness,
this little wing,
I really have the feeling of being a bird.
BG: How did you start to become Jetman?
YR: It was about 20 years ago,
when I discovered free falling.
When you go out of an airplane,
you are almost naked.
You take a position like that.
And especially when you take
a tracking position,
you have the feeling that you are flying.
And that's the nearest thing to the dream.
You have no machine around you.
You are just in the element.
It's very short and only in one direction.
(Laughter)
So the idea was, okay,
keep that feeling of freedom,
but change the vector
and increase the time.
BG: So I'm kind of curious,
what's your top speed?
YR: It's about 300 km per hour
before looping.
That means about 190 miles per hour.
BG: What's the weight
of the equipment you're carrying?
YR: When I exit full of kerosene,
I'm about 55 kilos.
I have 55 kilos on my back.
BG: And you're not piloting?
There is no handle, no steering, nothing?
It is purely your body,
and the wings become part
of the body and vice versa?
YR: That's really the goal,
because if you put in steering,
then you reinvent the airplane.
And I wanted to keep this
freedom of movement.
And it's really like the kid
playing the airplane.
I want to go down like that.
And up I climb, I turn.
It's really pure flying.
It's not steering, it's flight.
BG: What kind of training do you do,
you personally, for that?
YR: Actually, I try to stay just fit.
I don't do special physical training.
I just try to keep my mobility
through new activities.
For example, last winter
I began with kite surfing.
So, new things.
So you have to adapt.
I'm quite an experienced
manager of systems as a pilot,
but this is, really --
You need fluidity,
you need to be agile
and also to adapt really fast.
BG: Somebody in the audience asked me,
"How does he breathe up there?"
Because you're going fast
and you're up at 3,000 meters or so.
YR: Okay, up to 3,000 meters,
it's not such a big problem with oxygen.
But for example, bikers,
they have the same speed.
Just with the helmet, integral helmet,
it's really no problem to breathe.
BG: Describe for me the equipment,
since you have it here.
So Breitling's four engines.
YR: Yeah, two-meter span.
Ultra-stable profile.
Four little engines,
22 kilos thrust each,
turbines, working with kerosene.
Harness, parachute.
My only instruments
are an altimeter and time.
I know I have about eight minutes fuel.
So I just check before it's finished.
(Laughter)
And yeah, that's all.
Two parachutes.
That means, if I have a problem
with the first one I pull,
I still have the possibility
to open the second one.
And this is my life.
That's the real important
thing about safety.
I did use that during these last 15 years
about 20 times.
Never with that type of wing,
but at the beginning.
I can release my wing
when I am in a spin or unstable.
BG: We saw the 2009 crossing
of the Gibraltar Strait
where you lost control
and then you dived down into the clouds
and in the ocean.
So that was one of those cases
where you let the wings go, right?
YR: Yeah. I did try in the clouds,
but you lose orientation completely.
So I did try to take, again,
a climb altitude.
I thought, okay, I will go out.
But most probably,
I did something like that.
(Laughter)
BG: Something that is not
very safe, the image.
YR: You feel great, but --
(Laughter)
But you have not the right altitude.
So the next thing I saw was just blue.
It was the sea.
I have also an audible altimeter.
So I was at my minimum altitude
in that vector -- fast --
so I pulled that.
And then I did open my chute.
BG: So the wings have their own parachute,
and you have your two parachutes.
YR: Exactly. There is a rescue
parachute for the wing
for two reasons:
so I can repair it afterward
and especially so nobody takes
that, just on his head.
BG: I see. Maybe come back here.
This is risky stuff indeed.
People have died trying
to do this kind of thing.
And you don't look like a crazy guy;
you're a Swiss airline pilot,
so you're rather a checklist kind of guy.
I assume you have standards.
YR: Yeah. I have no checklist for that.
(Laughter)
BG: Let's not tell your employer.
YR: No, that's really two worlds.
Civil aviation is something
that we know very well.
We have a hundred years of experience.
And you can adapt really precisely.
With that, I have to adapt
to something new.
That means improvise.
So it's really a play
between these two approaches.
Something that I know
very well, these principles.
For example, we have
two engines on an Airbus;
with only one engine, you can fly it.
So plan B, always a plan B.
In a fighter, you have an ejection seat.
That's my ejection seat.
So I have the approach
of a professional pilot
with the respect of a pioneer
in front of Mother Nature.
BG: It's well said.
What happens if one of the engines stops?
YR: I do a roll.
And then I stabilize,
and according to my altitude,
I continue on two or three engines.
It's sometimes possible.
It's quite complicated to explain,
but according to which regime I was,
I can continue on two
and try to get a nice place to land,
and then I open my parachute.
BG: So the beginning of the flight
is actually you jump
off a plane or a helicopter,
and you go on a dive
and accelerate the engines,
and then you basically take off
mid-air somewhere.
And then the landing, as we have seen,
arriving on this side of the Channel,
is through a parachute.
So just as a curiosity,
where did you land when you flew
over the Grand Canyon?
Did you land on the rim,
down at the bottom?
YR: It was down on the bottom.
And I came back afterward
on the sled of the helicopter back.
But it was too stony
and full of cactus on top.
(Laughter)
BG: That's exactly
why I asked the question.
YR: And also, the currents
are quite funny there.
There is big thermal activity,
big difference in altitude also.
So it was much safer for me
to land at the bottom.
BG: I think that right now,
many people are asking,
"When are you developing a double-seater
so they can fly with you?"
YR: I have a standard answer.
Have you ever seen tandem birds?
(Laughter)
BG: Perfect answer.
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
BG: Yves, one last question.
What's next for you?
What's next for Jetman?
YR: First, to instruct a younger guy.
I want to share it,
to do formation flights.
And I plan to start from a cliff,
like catapulted from a cliff.
BG: So instead of jumping
off a plane, yes?
YR: Yes, with the final goal to take off,
but with initial speed.
Really, I go step by step.
It seems a little bit crazy, but it's not.
It's possible to start already now,
it's just too dangerous.
(Laughter)
Thanks to the increasing technology,
better technology,
it will be safe.
And I hope it will be for everybody.
BG: Yves, thank you very much. Yves Rossy.
(Applause)